-As I said earlier, the
Kentucky Derby is this Saturday.
Now, usually, there's a horse
that's a clear favorite,
but not this year.
It's nearly impossible
to predict the winner.
Well, you guys are in luck
because, when it comes
to predicting things,
we have a secret weapon,
and it's puppies.
-Aww.
-Whoo!
-That's right,
ladies and gentlemen --
it's time
for the Puppy Predictors,
2021 Kentucky Derby Edition.
-♪ Puppy predictors ♪
♪ Puppy predictors ♪
-Welcome to
the Puppy Predictors,
2021 Kentucky Derby Edition.
Here's how it works -- we have
10 adorable rescue puppies
from North Shore Animal League
America,
each representing one
of the top 10 horses
competing
in Saturday's big race,
and one giant trough of kibble.
Whichever puppy crosses
the finish line
and reaches the trough first
will be crowned
the Kentucky Derby winner.
Now, let's meet the puppies.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
I got -- Hi, everybody.
I know. I see you.
Hi, buddy.
Hi. I see you.
Hi, cutie. Hi, guys.
Oh, my.
They're ready to go.
Alright, lined up
at the starting gate,
we have Tigger representing
Essential Quality.
We have Maddie
for Rock Your World.
We have Reese for Known Agenda.
We have Addy
for Hot Rod Charlie.
We have Dorothy
for Highly Motivated.
Dorothy.
Wake up, Dorothy.
Get ready, Dorothy.
Dorothy. Now's the time
to shine, Dorothy.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Not gonna happen.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Not going to happen.
[ Chuckles ]
She made a choice early on --
yeah, nope.
We have Duncan for Mandaloun.
We have Keira for Medina Spirit.
We have Delilah
for Midnight Bourbon.
Delilah.
Ooh, look at -- look at Sissy.
Look at Sissy,
ready to go for King Fury.
Hi, Sissy.
And finally, we have Tiger
representing the long shot,
Dynamic One.
Tiger's not even looking
at the finish line.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Now, guys, before I release you,
listen up --
Tiger, you, as well --
no butt-sniffing, no cheating,
okay?
Let's make this a fair race.
First one to the trough wins --
okay? --
and wins the Kentucky Derby.
You guys got it?
Alright, cool.
Here we go.
Roots, whenever you're ready.
[ "First Call" plays ]
Okay.
Release the puppies!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hi, guys.
No, that way. Oh.
And we have a winner! Whoa!
[ Bell dinging ]
Hi, buddy.
[ Chuckling ] I know.
Okay. I know. I know.
Hi, buddy.
Oh, God. Wow. Are you kidding?
How cute is that?
Oh, I know. You didn't win,
but, gosh, you're cute.
Alright, oh.
Go over to Higgins.
There's the winner right here.
Oh, my goodness.
Hate to bring you away
from the food there, buddy.
There you go. Alright.
Come on up here, buddy.
Essential Quality is the winner
of the Kentucky Derby,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Look at this guy.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
If you'd like to adopt
one of these puppies,
go to animalleague.org.
He's so cute.
Enjoy the race. Stick around.
We'll be back with more
"Tonight Show," everybody.
Go, go, go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Enjoy. Hi! Hi!
[ Cheers and applause continue ]
♪♪